قالت صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت الاسرائيليه انه
في ظل التوترات بين جانس وبن كفير بشان
نهج القتال في غزه تشير التقديرات الى ان
الحكومه بتركيبتها الحاليه لن تبقى لفتره
اطول اذا لم ينسحب منها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن كفير من جهته قال
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي بن كفير ان
سبب عدم تمديد ولايه مفوضه مصلحه السجون
الاسرائيليه كاتي بيري يعود الى تسهل
مصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه مع اسرى حماس
وتفاوض معهم لتحسين ظروف اسرهم حسب تعبيره
من جانبها نقلت القناه الثانيه عش عن زعيم
حزب شاس اريه درعي قوله ان قرار عدم تمديد
ولايه مفوضه مصلحه السجون قد يؤدي لتفكيك
الحكومه والحاق اضرار جسيمه بالمجهود
الحربي
معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد هل يعني بمناسبه الخبر الذي
اضعناه للتو هل يعني ذلك وجود خلافات صارت
معلنه وتتحدث عنها الصحافه الاسرائيليه
داخل مجلس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي هو منذ تاسيس مجلس الحرب
واقامه حكومه الطوارئ التي انضم اليها
جانس وايزن كوت وحزبه من اجل بذري انهم
يريدون حشد الجهود من اجل الحرب والتوتر
قائم داخل مجلس الحرب وبين جانس ونتنياهو
لان نتنياهو يحاول ان يظهر بان جانس هو من
يعيق العمليات العسكريه وتصعيدها في قطاع
غزه مع العلم ان كافه المؤشرات تشير الى
عكس ذلك من هنا ياتي تحريك ابن كبير
الوزير وزير الامن القومي في ملف الاسرى
حاليا
ومحاوله منع
تمديد ولايه المفوضه مفوضه مصلحه السجون
بذري انها تتساهل مع الاسرى الفلسطينين
وتحديدا اسرى حركه حماس الاتفاق بين
نتنياهو وجانسل بان لا يتم مس او اي تحديد
اي تعيينات جديده في الم الظائف الكبيره
وتمديدها خلال فتره الحرب الى ان تنتهي
الحرب فجاءت حمله بن كفير والذي يعتقد
كثيرون بانها جاءت بتحريك ربما من نتنياهو
يعكس حاله التوتر بين نتنياهو وبين جانس
بهذا الخصوص من ناحيته جانس كان في الايام
الاخيره واضحا وقد استقام موقفه من الحرب
مع في قطاع غزه مع موقف نتنياهو الذي يقول
بانهم سيمضون فيها حتى نهايتها وحتى تحقيق
اهدافها لكن يتهمون بن كبير بانه قد حول
وزاره الامن القومي المسؤوله عن ملفات وعن
نظم هامه جدا مثل الشرطه ومصلحه السجون
والتي تعتبر من الانظمه الامنيه الهامه
حولها الى ما يشبه التنظيم السري له
ولحزبه وانه يريد ايضا محاوله تعزيز
سيطرته داخل السجون في اطار حملته
الانتقاميه من الاسرى الفلسطينيين والذي
التتي بداها مع اقامه حكومه نتنياهو
الحاليه التي تتم اليوم عامها الاول لذلك
يعتبر ما يجري بانه وان كان يخدم خطه بن
كبير الا انه يعكس ايضا التوتر داخل
الحكومه وتحديدا في مجلس الحرب بين جانس
ونتنياهو جانس يشعر بان هناك خرق
للتفاهمات وهذا ما جاء به اري دلعي زعيم
شاس الذي يطالب نتنياهو وبن كبير باحترام
هذه الاتفاقات كي لا تفرط الحكومه الحاليه
نهائيا وهم بحاجه لها جانس سيدلي ببيان
مساء هذا اليوم ويبدو انه سيتطرق الى هذه
المساله خاصه وان نتنياهو بات قلق من
تصاعد شعبيه جانس وتدني شعبيته في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ويريد اي خطوات من شانها ان
تخاطب قاعدته الانتخابيه لتط بعمر حكومته
ورئاسته لها لكن بن كبير يتصرف وكما اعلن
بنفسه بانه يتصرف وفق مصالحه لا وفق ما
يريده جانس وهذا يعكس حاله التوتر اما ان
تنهار الحكومه على خلفيه هذه المساله فهذا
في المرحله التاليه يبدو بعيدا لان جانس
ومعه ايزن كوت يتصرفان على اساس ان
المصلحه الوطنيه تتطلب بقائهما في هذه
الحكومه رغم كل المنغصات التي يقوم بها
نتنياهو شكرا جزيلا لك وليد العمري مكتب
الجزيره في رام
الله شكرا جزيلا لك